- Well I think the biggest
thing is I'm gonna bring him
to my coven.
He's convinced that Jesus
is gonna rock my world--
- She's gonna get saved.
Amen.
- Hail Satan.
Hi my name is Rachel and I'm a Satanist.
- My name is Matt and I'm a Christian.
- What I follow is Anton Lavey's Satanism
which is modern satanism.
Satan is just a Latin word for opposition.
We don't believe in like Addie
it's an over arching them
of unity with nature and self.
- So I'm a non denominational Christian.
I was brought up going to
church every single week
I worship just by prayer
I worship by living my
life and helping people.
- Honestly I'm a little scared.
I don't go to a party and be like,
hello it's me a satanist,
but that has happened to
me a lot with Christianity
where they're like have
you heard the good word?
- A lot of people around me
have reservations about going.
And I'm going why not?
It just gives us an
opportunity to show everybody
the love of Jesus Christ and
the power of the word of God
I'm super excited to meet Rachel.
- Hi.
- Hello.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- I know him--
- Oh my God!
- Hold on.
- We know each other.
- We met at Diane's house.
Oh, wow.
- Well I think the biggest
thing is that I'm gonna
bring him to my coven and
we're gonna chant together.
- I'm gonna be terrified.
- Well I'm gonna be
hungover at your church so.
- Okay.
- I can match that.
- You still can be saved
while being hungover.
- Oh hunny who said I need to be saved?
- So do you know what to do with these?
- You seem to know what to do with them.
- I may have been in them before.
- Okay okay Jesus boy I see you.
- Are you right handed or left handed?
- I'm right handed.
- I'm left handed.
- Okay yay see?
- It works.
- See?
- Two parts of a whole.
- Are you ready?
- I'm hungry.
- Yeah let's eat.
Let's go sacrifice a pig right?
I'm kidding that's a
joke, I'm kidding, okay.
- Dumplings while arrested.
No one--
- They're fine, they're like
it's normal, it's Hollywood,
people are handcuffed.
- Hollywood baby.
Yummy.
We have a lot of good
satanic stuff in here.
- Why is it dark.
- Oh my god it's so dark.
Welcome to your first party ceremony.
- Let's find preacher I wanna see this.
- Yes, this is book one too?
I might have to get this.
I was trying to show him
some like godly comic books
but turns out comic book
community is not a big fan of God.
- Yeah we like real things.
- Wow
- Party time
- Alright alright here we go.
- This is really good malt scotch whiskey.
- No.
- Okay I'm gonna pour you some.
- I don't know, this is.
- You're fine, you're fine,
loosen up a little bit
even God drank.
I don't wanna bite in,
- Just do it.
- I don't--
- I have to take my lipstick off.
- Your lipstick fine
- Hmm hmm I have to take it off.
Basically I'm here with some coven ladies
and Sam's gonna read Matt's tarot.
- This is your current
state, wheel of fortune
these are your hopes and fears,
it's like all of the material wealth
and like wisdom and
like all of the things.
- Matt how did you feel
about your first reading?
- I don't know if this
sways my life at all.
Here.
Look at this, look at that.
Oh my gosh.
- Yeah this is really good.
- It's like a little cushion.
- Goodnight.
- Rachel.
It's time to go to church.
- No.
- Yeah.
Are you ready to get saved?
- No.
- I guess we moved to a bed
in the middle of the night.
- I've never slept in the
same bed as a satanist before.
- I'm a lot of people's firsts.
- So there were times
last night that I was
I felt a little fear but I
didn't let that get in my way.
- Good.
- For God has not given us the spirit fear
and timidity but of power,
love and self discipline.
- Hakuna Matata.
- Hakuna?
Wow.
Come on.
It's time for church.
- Is this okay to wear to church?
- Yeah church is about coming as you are.
- Oh like that Nirvana song.
- Sure.
- I'm feeling a little weird honestly
I don't, I'm not looking forward to this.
- I'm excited, I'm excited.
- But I'm happy that Matt is excited.
- 30 seconds till church.
- How do you feel?
You got saved.
- No I didn't.
- You totally got saved,
she totally got saved.
- No I didn't.
- She rose her hand up high.
- 'cause you rose my hand up,
that was a non consensual praise hand.
- Her heart was so open.
- My hear was open.
Did I do okay?
- You did, you did, you did.
- Good, what's the hesitation I did fine.
- There was a little bit
of making fun but hey.
- Hey I'm sorry I can't help but laugh.
- It's okay, it's okay,
lord has a sense of humor,
God has a sense of humor.
- He literally was talking about the devil
and I couldn't help but laugh.
I really appreciate
being in an environment
where people feel a sense of community
and people feel empowered by
a thing and if they need God
to feel that way, great,
I just don't happen
to need God to feel that way.
I feel that way every day when I wake up
and I see myself in the mirror and I go
oh hell yes, yes queen.
- Well you certainly felt it in there.
- I definitely felt something in there.
- Love wins.
- Well we're gonna go get food now.
- Yes.
- Post church fuel up.
- Here we go, taking in.
- We got Mediterranean
meal to appease Jesus.
Well my Sundays are a
little different from this.
I usually wake up late
and then I go to brunch.
- There's no rest for the wicked.
- Guess not, you know me so well
I'm good and I'm bad, duality of man
as above so below, you
can't knock me from this.
- I really liked you more than
I like you in this moment.
- Good.
- Can I give you a hug?
- No.
- Please?
- I love you.
- Shh, I love you too.
I was actually really surprised
at how genuinely nervous I
was and I really didn't know
what to expect I thought
that I was gonna feeL like
a lamb just slaughtered and I kinda did
but it wasn't terrible
it was so much better than
what I expected it really was.
The most important thing to
take from this experience
about satanism in general is that it's not
what you think it is,
it's all about humanity
and finding love and
finding God within your,
the other, the people on
earth and what you can share
tangibly.
- I think that in the
world that we live in today
trump's america, the muslim
ban and things like that
I just think that if I a Christian
can be handcuffed to a satanist
for an entire weekend I
think our entire country
can do the same and bridge any gap.
- One thing that I think both Christians
at least the church that we were at today
and satanists have in common is that
we need to unify as people.
- I'm going to miss Rachel so much.
I am not going to miss this.
I love you and Jesus loves you.
- Amen.
- Hey, Amen.
She wanted to uncuff so bad.
- I did.
Oh.
- Oh my god do you have a mark?
- Bye!
- No don't I want to hug.